el partido mismo la frencia insumisa
realizó un sondeo para saber cómo van a
votar el próximo domingo las personas de
ese partido lo que se tiene por
resultados es que un tercio de ellos
votará por emanuel macon pero los otros
dos tercios por una parte piensan ya sea
votar en blanco o abstenerse en realidad
según algunos sondeos porque de hecho en
esta en esta digamos en esta encuesta no
se preguntaba si en últimas también
votarían por a marín lópez en realidad
esto digamos que esta opción no aparecía
porque eso lo que me lo dio ese día de
una vez se conocieron los resultados de
la primera vuelta dijo que ningún voto
debía ir a la extrema derecha entonces
allí lo que sucede es que hay muchos
sondeos que en realidad están tratando
de saber cuál sería el porcentaje de
esas personas que darían ese giro de 180
grados y bueno en realidad sería entre
el 16 y el 27 por ciento que estarían
dispuestos a votar por la candidata
ultraderechista y como éste le decía
pues son jugosos esos votos que necesita
emanuel marco y de hecho lo que ha
venido haciendo sobre todo al final de
la semana pasada con su gran mitin de
campaña en la ciudad es esa la de ir por
ese voto joven aquellas personas entre
los 18 y los 35 años que votaron en su
mayoría por
melón son sobre todo pues hablando
principalmente de ecología y retomando
algunas ideas también del jefe de los
insumisos